the first story that I wanted a share of
this new work is a story about tiger
sharks now tiger sharks if you read the
literature described as the most
dangerous shark in tropical waters
they've considered the second most
dangerous species of shark overall after
the great white they've certainly been
portrayed as mindless monsters but in
reality the the cutting-edge science
that's being done right now is showing
the teaser animals and actually have a
pretty high degree of cognition and they
have the ability to learn and the
ability to remember can't get into all
that right now but but this is some of
the stuff that will be published I think
in the time ahead they're also one of
the most versatile species of sharks you
know one day they'll be hunting in a
thousand meters of deep pacific water
and the very next day they'll be in a
marina looking for fish scraps under a
fisherman's boat when they're born tiger
sharks look like this they have this
amazingly stunning pattern of stripes
which of course is where they get the
name from the tiger like stripes that
they have on their body this was a
neonate just a few days old that I
photographed in Hawaii last year those
stripes begin to fade as the animal gets
a little bit older and they're not quite
as as vivid in and quite striking
but in you know the 20 years or so I've
been diving from about 40 years but for
about 20 years of my career I was very
interested in finding tiger sharks but
had almost no success I would do trips
to various places but never really found
them in any predictable way but a number
of years ago a buddy of mine that ran
around the dive business out of Palm
Beach Florida discovered a place in the
Bahamas in the northern Bahamas that he
named Tiger Beach and this is an aerial
view I use the National Geographic blimp
to do a low altitude aerial shot here
and this is a place it's a sort of a
sandy shallow sand flat area in the
northern Bahamas where these animals
can't congregate you'll find on any
given day a dozen or more of them so we
see a bunch of these big old Tigers
hanging out behind the boat perfect day
to go swimming
you see right here and this is this is
what it looks like underwater this is
the scene underwater you can swim down
about maybe 20 feet or so and find
yourself in the company of these big
tiger sharks you know many of these are
between 12 and 14 feet in length and
they'll come up very close to give you
some great close-up encounters not using
any cages here or anything and it's a
pretty extraordinary thing to be able to
see these animals like this and and to
be in their presence you know the first
time I did it I was in my heart was
racing through my chance but over time
you you never fully let your guard down
but I think you you relaxed at least a
little bit to some extent part of the
approach that I took this time when I
was out there for this latest story in
the magazine was to try to show these
animals a little bit like their
terrestrial namesake to try to make
pictures that looked a little bit like a
tiger on land maybe you know making its
way through the grasses of in do
something channeling my inner Steve
winter here but you know there but the
difference was of course I wasn't on the
back of an elephant you know so you have
to be know I die with these guys and and
that's what some people like to do you
like do you have a little conversation
with tiger sharks you know just how was
your day kind of have a little chat here
like this divers doing actually this is
showing the the fact that ecotourism has
really prospered in this place ever
since the discovery of tiger beach a
number of companies have sprung out be
kotor ISM dive companies that will get
you out there and get you in in the
company of tiger sharks like we see
right here sometimes it can get a little
dicey especially when you get multiple
sharks coming around but in my
experience is out there in the weeks
that I've spent out in Tiger Beach I
have to say that they're all very well
behaved but generally well behaved for
the most part occasionally they'll try
to eat my camera like this one did right
here but he once they realized that it's
not especially tasty they they sort of
just move on and during my time out
there on these recent trips I also
wanted to move away from those shallow
sandy places Tiger Beach proper and try
to photograph tiger tracks out in the
deeper weeks because they hang out there
- lots of tigers in the Bahamas and I
wanted to see if I could get you know
the lord of the reef sort of patrolling
over these these sponges and coral
that we see here or to look at you know
the behaviors of multiple animals we do
see a lot of different sharks here and
there there definitely seems to be sort
of some higher rocky some social
behavior it's not fully understood I
mean to some degree it's usually the big
shark wins the other one usually goes
the other way but but there is something
going on there that I think will figure
out in time and you know we see this a
lot - sharks with hooks in their mouths
and it's not it's not relegated only to
tiger sharks pretty much everywhere I go
in the world you see evidence of fishing
pressure this Tiger had two big hooks in
its mouth but we see jewelry as it's
often called on many sharks all over the
world it's a it's a very troubling trend
that seems to be happening everywhere
and thanks to a grant from the National
Geographic Society on these these latest
projects we were also able to fund some
some research out there this is in the
and the right of the frame this is dr.
Neil ham Hamish lag from the University
of Miami who's been studying tiger
sharks in this region for some time and
one of the ways he does this is he built
this special platform that can submerge
just below the back of our boat you tie
it up to the back of the boat and then
he brings a tiger shark in and I'm not
sure his insurance company of seeing
these pictures but but nonetheless what
could go wrong and and he brings it in
and then they they work up the Sharks
they do some science here but the
standard procedure has always been to
measure the shark take a DNA clipping
you know maybe a fin clipping for DNA
sample they tag the shark usually
sometimes that's done surgically they
implant a body cavity tag so they can
track the animal over time but some of
the newest research is ultrasound work
that's going on right here and that's
what this woman researcher is doing in
the center of the frame here with the
goggles because Tiger Beach it's been
discovered seems to be a maternity ward
most of the sharks there are females and
many of them are pregnant and that
shallow warm water seems to promote
gestation so they're doing these
sonograms that they can keep a video
graph of and they can see how many pups
are inside and then the tagging data
will show where the animal goes
don't actually have their pups in the
Bahamas they're going up into northern
Florida Georgia water so in terms of
conservation this would be a very
critical habitat we might want to
protect in the future and we also did
some credit cam work I think so most of
you might know about national
Geographics Crittercam where they attach
cameras and various scientific
instruments to animals and let them sort
of carry it and then it pops off this is
the first time that one had been
attached and deployed underwater so this
is Neil Hamish lag after he just put
that thin clamp on the tiger shark here
and he's sort of checking it making sure
it's alright and then off it goes for
the better part of a day recording both
video and all kinds of other data and
here we can see the sharks that are
swimming around a little shark cameraman
here just another example of animal
taking our job but but in any case you
know what this this date I mean they
only did it a little bit while we were
out there but it did yield some
interesting thing you know most of the
eco tourism operators they're out there
felt that they knew exactly what these
sharks are doing they're going from one
Operator to the next you know and just
staying on that shallow area but the the
Cree cam showed that in between some of
those visits they're making these very
deep dives we don't quite know exactly
what's happening down there but clearly
there's a lot more going on in these
animals lives than we realize here's a
little video that I wanted to share
behind the scenes just a short video
[Music]
just give you a sense of what it's like
to be down there with those giant
animals it can be a little unnerving at
times but as I said it's all been pretty
good so this sum for that same story on
tiger sharks I also work in South Africa
this is a photo my assistant made of me
on assignment here with a tiger shark up
in the water column and this site is a
new site that was sort of discovered by
a researcher named dr. Ryan Daly it's up
near the Mozambique border and what Ryan
Daley found is that there's a deep water
reef there the tiger shark seemed to
frequent but if we dive in the shallow
waters just below the surface Tigers
will often rise up and so to check us
out and he's just beginning his research
out there to find out what these animals
are do and where they're going and so
forth but he invited me to come out and
it was a chance for me to make pictures
in a sort of different environment
instead of being on the bottom but these
are completely wild sharks they're not
acclimated or habituated to humans
whatsoever
very very wild and you're definitely
part of the food chain when you're when
you're out there and on the like Tiger
Beach you can't stand on the bottom you
don't have that sort of safety blanket
of being able to stand on the bottom so
you're really kind of out there but I
have another little video that shows
what we would do a video job I see
melisandre bonamana come on
my Allah my Allah my Allah love Italy
doc you're gonna be pharmacy on another
problem as it all you know they're due
to Ali's who that you too
[Music]
none not where is Nam a lot more work to
do in South Africa so these are just a
few frames that I made of those sharks
and again they have sort of a different
look up in the Bluewater they're big
beefy sharks a little bit unnerving when
they come real close to you but you know
a stunning scene this was one that was
just covered in remoras adorned in
remoras it was actually a silver tip
shark in the bottom right of the frame
there were many other species out there
dusky sharks and bull sharks but the
Tigers of course that I was interested
in but when sort of turning you know
it's one of those things when you're in
the water out there you know you want to
get close to them and then when all the
sudden one turns and starts coming at
you you're not so sure you want to be
closer to many more it's really that
interesting dance that that we do in the
water out there well anyway the next
shark that I wanted to share with you
one of the four is the shortfin mako the
mako shark and you know I have to say
being in the water with all sharks is
pretty extraordinary and I love looking
at all animals but there is truly
something very special about being in
the water with a mako I've always found
these animals they tend to be coastal
animals but but not really close you
don't see them swimming over the bottom
you have to go several miles offshore
and try to attract them difficult to
attract but when you do see them you
know they just come in all jacked up
just sort of powering their way through
the water just full of muscle this was
one that I photographed in San Diego I
work in a few places San Diego New
Zealand and in Rhode Island for Makos
but this was one in beautiful blue water
off the San Diego bite when the Sun was
shining on a on a beautiful September
day but you know these are very scary
animals this is probably the last thing
that a yellowfin tuna sees before it's
lights out there are ambush predators
Makos you know attack from below they
have that big eye that allows them to
see very well in deep dark waters and to
be able to look up and and see those
patterns
and then when they see a prey fish they
come up and so often bite the tail off
of their prey whether it's a tuna or a
Marlin or something like that
and then wait for it to bleed out a
little bit circle around and then come
in and finish it off and those are the
things that are always foremost in my
mind when I'm swimming with a mako and
it's nipping at my fins
I've actually switched my fans I just
have these split fins that looked a
little bit like a fish and so now I've
gone with something that like too big
two by fours on my feet something that
looks very unfished like but you know
everything about this animal says
predator it's it's really built like a
torpedo with teeth just pure muscle and
all about all about feeding now I also
wanted a share sort of a little inside
baseball story about shark diving you
know a lot of shark operators over the
last few years have taken to using music
on their boat to try to attract certain
species of sharks as places where they
do that with great whites and Australia
other places for blue sharks and so
forth but Makos are very elusive I've
been trying to dive with Makos for
decades and had very little success I
mean on this story I had some luck but
they're very hard to get to come close
to the boat and a lot of times when they
do come close they're just in for a few
seconds or a minute and then and then
they're gone so I've had my best luck by
trying the music thing you know I
actually went out there and tried music
but what I've learned was that the only
music that actually works for Makos is a
CDC these are just badass sharks I mean
that's just that's just all there is to
it
and I'm not kidding I mean we've been
out there I've been out in San Diego and
New Zealand for days you know when
nothing was happening
and I look at my assistants say you know
time for a little ac/dc and not every
time but a lot of times you see a mako
come in so this was one in New Zealand
which is sort of Makos central or so
they call him there Matt Oh Matt go
central there's a lot of them around and
there are days where we had maybe a
dozen essaouira around us and water it
gets a little too crazy when that
happens but you know even the little
ones this is another one in San Diego
even the little ones come
with attitude you know they're like they
come in hot and they're all fierce and
bitey
Mako's we'll just bite things they don't
have hands and there's just all jacked
up it's like they're on cocaine or
something you know not that I would know
but people have told me but and you know
that one had these copepods on its
dorsal fin and this was another one a
bigger animal that was swimming down in
that beautiful blue water off California
here and they they often get those
parasites on their on the dorsal looks
like little streamers kind of hanging
off there but this diving like the the
Tigers I always do without cages you
know it would just be impractical to try
to get photographs because the animals
are so unpredictable they don't stick
around very long
and they would almost never come over to
a cage so you have to sort of be out
there in the open and most times I'm
diving alone because I don't want even
one other person in the water that might
spook the shark but sometimes I'll have
an assistant in and sometimes you'll
carry just a little stick there's a sort
of a deterrent if the animal gets a
little too aggressive which has happened
a few times but for the most part they
they don't do that though they will come
in and and check you out a little bit
but these are these are animals that are
endothermic meaning that they can
generate heat in their body it was
Brooke Burnett actually a National
Geographic who who turned the phrase hot
sharks these are hot sharks because they
can generate heat in their body and
because of that they can swim into
colder water and feed on oilier fish and
so forth but the mako is also one of the
fastest animals in the ocean a mako
shark can swim at bursts of over 45
miles an hour underwater in fast bursts
and you kind of remember that underwater
that the medium is much thicker than in
air so that's probably like swim in 100
miles an hour or something but
extraordinary animals and in in San
Diego I wanted to try to hang out near
kelp patties in the kelp forests of
California kelp giant kelp will often
break off and mat up and and drift along
the coast in its own little ecosystem
forms we get little fish and then bigger
fish and sometimes you get Dorado
mahi-mahi and fish like that and I spent
weeks out there trying to get a picture
of a mako near one and that's what we
see hunt and didn't actually get them
predating but but I don't think anything
like this had ever been made
so that was a kind of a cool thing as
well but you know these are the moments
I dream about right here for a when a
big ol mako shark comes in and bites the
crap out of my down port fetch that's
heaven but you know I honestly try to
resist the temptation of making scary
pictures of sharks because I really
don't want to perpetuate that myth and
enough damage has been done to sharks
over the years but by the same token I
don't want to sort of portray them as
something that they're not I don't want
to show them as house pets or give the
impression that you know they're cuddly
and we can go out and hug a shark
because they're not their real predators
so I think you know we have to walk that
that fine line and and show them for
what they are but but not over demonize
them for sure and with the same story I
also wanted to spend some time looking
at shark tournaments because you know
there's still a lot of this thing going
on where there will be these monster
shark tournaments held in various places
so this summer I spent a couple of days
in Montauk New York where they they hold
these tournaments for a couple of days
and they give prize money for the
biggest shark killed and it oftentimes
is a mako or a thresher but you know I
think that the time has passed for this
kind of thing when you consider that a
hundred million sharks are being killed
every year I don't really think there's
a benefit to sort of glamourizing
killing these animals in the two days
that I was in in Montauk I saw six
sharks come in no I'm sorry twelve there
was six Makos and six threshers and
every single one of them was a juvenile
every single one wasn't even old enough
to reproduce and you know I watched them
drag these things up on the on the dock
and sort of cut them up and I saw all
these children these kids that were
fascinated with sharks you know but I
think it's sort of unfortunate that this
is their first scene of a shark you know
looking like a slayed dragon just laid
there and that the fisherman was some
sort of heroes for doing this and I have
no problem with fishing but I just think
the time has passed for this sort of
treatment of sharks and you know I
recognize that not everyone will get to
see a shark underwater probably the way
that they should be seeing this amazing
Lima Jets majestic animal you know we we
can appreciate lions and grizzly bears
and tigers and so forth but underwater
these animals are just slaughtered and
often with little regard so my hope is
this photography can sort of move that
that forward a little bit in terms of
some appreciation and one of the other
things I wanted to do with with this
story with video actually was to show
the speed of a mako attacking something
so with the grant from the Geographic
Society I designed with my assistant at
Woods Hole Oceanographic we designed a
tow camera system I found an industrial
camera that shot at very high speed I
could shoot at 720 frames a second we
built this tow camera and I worked with
a New Zealand
champion sport fisherman who fished from
Marlin and he would rig a mullet bait
type of fish called mullet and trail it
behind the boat from Marlin but he said
oftentimes Makos would attack it so I
was there for a couple of weeks but I
only got one day where I could do it so
I've got a two-minute video with no
sound but I'll just have a look at that
and show you this is the first time this
has ever been seen of a mako and
high-speed attacking something a mullet
everything that you're going to see here
happened in about four seconds but we're
shooting so fast that we can play it
back at normal speed and it's it's slow
motion but it was fascinating you see
this animal after he latched on sort of
put his pectoral fins back in a very
hydrodynamic way almost trying to use
his weight and the speed to break it off
the boat was traveling at about eight
knots and he had no trouble of course
you know firing up and going in and
grabbing that bait but it was
interesting to see that behavior I think
researchers haven't showed this to
scientists yet but I think they'll be
interested to see this form that the
Mako assumes once he's bitten into the
prey just a truly remarkable predator
for sure
going for ride they can sort of detach
their jaws like a great white as well
and realize that if you can see it
coming out it's a pretty pre mazing
behavior from a mako shark shout at 720
frames a second